whoever is waiting on that loses whoever
makes it to the losers finals let me
just say
good luck because you're going to need
it yeah it's definitely going to be
tough either way again
we're not even at the very end for the
challenges you mentioned and there's
still
so many great players left it's going to
take a lot to be able to really come out
on top and be the best so
again king of the hill challenge this is
what it all comes down to we are
uh winding down to our final six players
continuing onwards here is more losers
bracket action
and this is a match we don't even see
that often it's yoshimitsu vs lucky
chloe all right here we go
yukio back at it again kaiser man yukio
was doing some crazy evasive stuff
earlier in that matchup versus ben chang
so i'm interested to see you think
that's gonna play out here
i mean lucky chloe definitely has been
another character that has some pretty
invasive stuff
uh some crushing stuff i should say and
movement is the name of the game we're
gonna get into it as it still syncs up
all right game number one here loser
side oh
just starts off with it wow oh i like it
the the mind games are plenty already
goes for the power crush
i like yukio keeping the wits about
himself
once again the low follow up and i like
to switch up kind of goes for the mid
just to see if yukiya was ducking
there's the flash
and this is going to be quite the hill
to climb right here this is going to be
a lot
i mean he does have rage and he has an
opportunity all you need is
oh my god right through the power crush
are you serious wow steve your your
mouth is open still steve calm down
oh my gosh i was that was one
of rob's like what i can't believe you
threaded that needle with that blade
that was crazy
no wonder kudimi to try to steal that
sword away right makes magic happen
yo eva thank you for dropping the blue
stuff thank you
i was way too in shock wow completely
gets around it
nice gets the low option as well oh my
gosh
that driver's high since that hit it's
been momentum all the way
oh unblockable go straight for the reset
i like this
oh there you go you gotta lay there
still gets the tail spin at the end
small combo on the wall
and still trying to get the flash bounce
oh what did i say what's that noise
doesn't matter
gets the did neither up for four is this
hit yes
okay i i wasn't sure what combo he was
going for yukio takes it three
rounds straight over kaiser in this
first game and loses quarters
don't forget man the way that ukiyo was
playing in the winter semis earlier
today he was on fire you know even
though he lost that set
he was playing some of the best tekken
i've seen him play against bin chang
he's still continuing carrying that
momentum that he had from that crazy
matchup earlier
into this matchup going up against
kaiser and you know he just steamrolled
him through that first match
i mean this is this is where it counts
though but we saw this last time in
kaiser's match we saw this
versus uh shinzo earlier where um
they were playing each other and that
first game did not look like it was
going to go kai's way
it just seemed like you know just
uncomfortable in the matchup and there
are a lot of players out there
that need that first game to kind of get
a you know get a feel for what their
opponent is going for and i feel like
kaiser might be that kind of player
going into this next match it's not
going to be easy
but still has a game to stay alive even
on this losing side
oh yeah that's for sure and again if you
guys are just tuning in we're in the
middle of our top eight
a lot of action happening here for the
tekken 7 king of the hill finals
my name is mark i'm here joined with
tasty steve steve how are you feeling
today
i look i'm just enjoying these matches i
feel like it's really cool because
we don't typically see a bunch of these
characters even though we see these
players pretty frequently
these guys have gotten good enough now
to where they're like pulling out
multiple characters so
i'm just honestly i'm still looking at
the character variety that we're saying
right we're seeing kuni mitsu we got a
yoshi in here as well
we've seen a master raven you know we
got a lucky chloe still
going strong we got a king as well i
mean we got brian
we gotta knock this in the top eight and
we already said look i know you guys are
thinking like yo man what about this
knox
knock this we already showed you that
the dlc is on sale so if you like what
you see
just go pick it up yourself and try it
at home but here we go we're going back
into it the next match here at the king
of the hill finals for tekken 7.
hey not just that not only do we have
these great matches that are happening
steve we have a special announcement
that is going to be coming up
very shortly so i hope everybody is
looking forward to that if you don't
already let your friends know
twitch.tv slash tekken is the place to
be there is some good ass tekken
information that's going to be coming up
right now going back into the match
though
i mean it's going to be tough let's see
if kaiser can come back here that
steamrolling
of a first game from ukiyo has been uh
it made a definite impression on me he's
here to win he's here to win now this is
what we were talking about last time
kaiser playing a little slower in that
first game and still yukio with the
league yukio
had so much tech though just dealing
with you know
[ __ ] rom didn't get the w but still
just seems very very well versed in how
to deal with a series of matchups
with yoshi flash right after it and this
is looking a little
smooth selling for yukio right now in
this first round game number two
nice job
what did i say you killed you killed
a master a master knows his surroundings
he knows it so well
oh we're punished too
and now i feel like kaiser is getting a
little too antsy yukio using that
that impatience against them
not only that it's the patience like you
said the spacing the knowledge here
from ukiyo it's helping out a lot i mean
obviously very close on life here
but counter hit that's going to be the
round yukio looking
so clean two rounds straight and kaiser
is definitely on tilt right now only a
kickstand keeping my mans alive right
now
on the loser's side gonna need can not
lose another round or will be out of the
tournament
still trying to play it slow what a
whiff punish gets the hop kick
wall big damage
and look at the carry on that as well
uh-oh right now himself quick side step
nice block oh you get the launch though
still with the likely did you do
something crazy the flash is still there
just waits for it gets the full launch
kaiser half-life this is looking a lot
more comfortable for him
oh yeah good patience there hop kick
staying in place
this is straight up hop kick
no break on wow once again just using
the mix-ups of lucky chloe
and now just running away with it just
running what did i say
follows up with the seven golden letters
you can cash that in
two rounds can't lose this one can't
lose this next one
one more round and we get another game
from kaiser and yukio and this is
definitely starting to look like
something that kaiser can actually do
with this lucky clothes
um look at the back she don't take off
damage huh that was a back turn combo
dude
gets the launcher wait a minute
count 4-1 beats the power crush rainbow
now i want to taste the rainbow blocks
the power crush oh my gosh it comes out
of this oh
oh the slow-mo oh my god
steve you i i felt my arm twitch there i
was doing it in my mind bro
i was doing it with my mind i actually i
didn't see it but i reached to my
right and this is how look look how
instinctual that is i've gotten so
strong i can do it through the internet
i was like
oh there's nobody there other than i was
like oh yeah here we go i felt something
i felt something right here
just so you know i felt something
boy these matches are sick i'm telling
you i'm getting powerful man
december 21st bro i'm doing i'm starting
to do it with my mind my abilities are
manifesting
i'm gonna start grabbing people through
the internet just shaking them just
shaking them through the internet
well i i'm definitely shook here
especially because we are now going to a
final game between these players
and man i did not think kaiser had it in
him after that first match but look at
here look at what we got here we
definitely have ourselves
quite the set between these two players
this is going to be good one of these
players are actually going home man one
of these players are actually going home
and the back and forth between these two
is getting really good
what did i say that kaiser does very
well the adjustments in the second game
added up ran it back
three rounds to steal that match i said
could not lose any more rounds
the fact that that match is under
kaiser's belt means we got one more game
to play
personally i feel like this is gonna be
a back and forth i would be surprised
that we don't go around for round
in this next match
oh man uh king of the hill this is
we're not even at the end we still have
that challenge match later we have that
announcement that's gonna be coming up
as well
i can't wait i actually i can't wait for
everything i can't wait
to see what first off i want to see what
this special announcement is
uh two these matches are getting so
sick and we're not even at winners
finals yet this is just still part of
the loser side of top eight
we're going into the final match we have
kaiser in that lucky chloe
going up against this yoshi miss you
yoshimitsu coming from yukio and i have
to say
i am a fan
all right everybody that has been tuning
in thanks for watching we are down to
our final match here between these two
players and we're going to be continuing
throughout our entire top eight
as we find out who is going to be the
champion for today's tournament after
that they are going to be going up
against glaciating who is our current
king of the hill
to find out who will be the king of the
hill the reigning champion from this
entire series of events throughout our
community
but right now going into the match up
here tied up 1-1 instant
instant low from kaiser oh and look at
this
hey yeah you thought it was going smooth
didn't you floor break
i said hey i got a big shipment it's
called lucky chloe damage oh my god
jesus is that going to put the stop here
oh
i can get the floor break myself let me
get this shark week though steve it's
sharp
shark week a very dangerous week on the
tekken channel and the discovery channel
oh oh my gosh wasn't enough it was not
enough but that was a great attempt
there at the rage art
uh i gotta say man kaiser is looking
really good he's playing with a
different level of confidence from what
we saw earlier ukiyo
now kind of put into the the scene where
he's just kind of
watching and reaction reacting to the
the matchup so far
earlier he was just going wild oh my
gosh i think right now kaiser's playing
where he's going to make yukio
you're going to test how fast yukio can
play and keep track of what lucky chloe
can do damage wise
big damage here oh no the drop oh he
tried to flash punishing
he got kind of greedy there oh but this
is not going to be good
you might be able to close it out here
but the side wall it doesn't matter what
did i say
didn't i say they're gonna go back to
back round four round didn't i say this
i mean it ain't over yet but let's see
let's see how far we're gonna go
launcher here
could possibly get the wall uh uh okay
you know all these blocks on the running
low here for kaiser that's going to open
up
again for the mix-up of the running mid
attack he has not done it yet so far but
again i wouldn't be surprised if he
started pulling it out of the matchup
doesn't matter the ukio says not not in
my house we're at the bottom floor here
this is where the sharks live
what are you gonna do nice wow basic
punish spending life
to take life i like it the spin oh for
buckingham i mean up four four excuse me
four three the yo man with the yo gang
looking to close it out here what are
you gonna do these lows they're adding
oh it's done it's not that's the no no
no the mutombo hit him with a no no no
that's what he's doing at the spin no no
no no no no just hitting you raw with
the ross the mutombo
i'ma call her that from now on every
time yoshimitsu
hits you with the walk no no no no no no
no
not in my house the wall is my house you
better not
wow yukio plain and simple that last
game
three rounds straight kaiser what a
showing nonetheless
we talked about how often we see
yoshimitsu we don't get to see him that
much
but even more so we get to see more uh
lucky chloe's out here
with kaiser as well as just the
yoshimitsu
so hey steve i gotta say you have a nice
shirt on
mark i would have to say you have a dope
shirt on too i mean it might be a little
different but
the love is just the same these good ass
tekken shirts
available now and for a limited time and
i know you got a smartphone
so make the smart choice scan the qr
code and get yourself
some of this good ass tekken merch you
can see the king shirt right there i'm
rocking the blue one of my favorite
colors anyway with one of my favorite
characters and you see mark man
rocking the bruce lee classic long
yellow also comes in black and if you
want to be like
rip you want to be like law use that qr
code get it right now
it's for a limited time only and it
starts right now
on top of that we have the cute ass
tekken line coming down
as well we got this yoshimitsu that you
just seen
in both black and white and of course
it's available now and for a limited
time that cute ass tech in the qr code